kovy de monde la russie affiche un
triste record plus de 1000 morts en 24
heures 1064 précisément 9 flambées
épidémiques que les autorités veulent
contenir rapidement avec des mesures
sanitaires strictes un confinement
parcelles pour moscou la mise en place
d'une semaine chômé au niveau national
les détails depuis moscou de notre
correspondante verhaeghe au final c'est
officiel vladimir poutine a décrété une
période chômée en russie à partir du 30
octobre au 7 novembre les régions où la
situation est la plus compliquée pour
ont instauré des mesures restrictives
plutôt à partir du 23 octobre est
prolongé leur confinement après le 7
novembre selon le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov il est impossible
pour l'instant de prévoir l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire est donc délicat
de prédire quelles seront les
restrictions nécessaires après la fin de
la période chaud mais je vous propose
d'écouter
vacciner plus longtemps qu'un certain
nombre de pays européens
moins de gens sont vaccinés et à mesure
que de nouvelles souches plus agressive
apparaissent le nombre de personnes
malades augmente c'est la réalité de la
situation à laquelle nous faisons face
mais en même temps les médecins ont déjà
développé des méthodes et protocoles de
traitement le nombre de lits a été
augmentée on a mieux organiser la
logistique nécessaire il s'agit surtout
de la fourniture d'oxygène etc on a une
grande réserve équipements de protection
individuelle et d'autres types de
matériaux et d'équipements un immense
travail a été réalisé dans ce domaine le
problème qui se pose en ce moment est
celui de la conscience des citoyens
[Musique]
je parle de la trajectoire de la
pandémie dans notre pays je parle de la
trajectoire de la pandémie dans d'autres
pays étant donné le trop faible niveau
de vaccination de la population
moscou est le principal foyer épidémique
est selon le maire de la capitale
servier ce bénigne la ville devrait
atteindre les pics historiques de
contamination au qu'ovide dans les
prochains jours il est prévu de fermer
du 30 octobre au 7 novembre les
restaurants les salles de sport les
centres commerciaux les salons de beauté
ou encore les cinémas les magasins
d'aliments si on est les pharmacies
continueront toutefois à fonctionner
selon diniz protsenko médecin chef de
l'hôpital comme monarque a le plus grand
hôpital russe chargé du traitement du
corona virus la semaine chaud mais le
seul moyen de freiner l'épidémie vu le
taux encore assez faible de personnes
vaccinées à peine 48 millions ayant
bénéficié d'une vaccination complète sur
une population de plus de 144 millions
d'habitants écoutez maintenant une pause
est indispensable il n'y a pas
d'alternative ici soit tout le monde va
se faire vacciner en masse soit on
commence à tomber malade tout aussi
massivement et à développer notre propre
immunité
si on prend la seconde option tout sera
moins prévisible et contrôlables que si
on prend la première dans le cadre du
système de santé de notre pays il est
impossible de faire en sorte qu
absolument tous les lits disponibles
soient destinés aux maladies
infectieuses
il y aura encore et encore de telles
jours fériés jusqu'à ce que nous
développions une immunité collective
jusqu'à ce que nous commencions à
utiliser notre tête et à respecter les
gens qui nous entourent porter des
masques dans les lieux publics ne pas
venir au travail avec des symptômes
d'infection respiratoire virale aiguë
nous avons déjà perdu trop de temps ne
voit encore des contaminations
aujourd'hui en russie près de trente
sept mille cas de corona virus détecté
dans le pays dont plus de 8000 à moscow
le nombre de décès a de nouveau franchi
le cap de 1000 personnes s'élève en ce
vendredi à 1064